fue una decisión difícil para esta chica
de 23 años que no quiere compartir su
nombre al saber que estaba embarazada
decidió que prefería terminar la
universidad antes de tener hijos así que
acudió una clínica para abortar con el
temor de que pronto florida revoque el
derecho a interrumpir voluntariamente el
embarazo
con lo de romper sus wait honestamente
me ha dado miedo no sabía si florida
siendo un estado republicano iba a
cambiar su decisión por lo que sentí que
era urgente tomar mi decisión
mcquaid chahuán fue no es la única desde
que en junio el tribunal supremo de eeuu
revocó el derecho federal al aborto y
distintos estados vecinos empezaron a
imponer restricciones el número de
personas que viajan a florida para
abordar ha aumentado en esta clínica de
west palm beach el número de pacientes
se ha duplicado según cuentan sus
profesionales we just for working howard
y shawn days nuestros trabajadores a
veces trabajan 12 horas al día hemos
abierto algunos centros de salud los
fines de semana he incorporado a más
médicos
y algunos de ellos vienen de estados con
las restricciones al aborto más severas
del país no pueden asistir a los
pacientes en sus propios estados así que
se ofrecieron a trabajar con nosotros
aquí en florida
pese a que florida es uno de los pocos
estados del sureste donde el aborto
todavía es legal el gobernador ron de
santis impulsó la prohibición de
interrumpir la gestación pasadas las 15
semanas de embarazo la ley fue
suspendida por la justicia pero luego
reinstaurada mientras el gobierno
republicano quiere revocar años de
avances organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos de las mujeres luchan para que
el tribunal superior de florida lo
reafirmé